est-ce que vous recevez des politiques
dans balances ton post pour vous
construire une autre légitimité pas du
tout ça a été le hasard vraiment parce
qu'on a démarré balances ton post cette
émission de débat et puis après on a eu
un politique puis deux puis ça commença
à m'amuser parce que pouvait leur poser
des questions voilà que je pouvais pas
posée aux autres et il me met une
pression lui font les yeux dans les yeux
pourquoi n'avez vous pas pu retenir
camille combal alors pas d'argent je ne
suis pas très fin ouais non non et puis
je crois qu'il avait un rêve c'était
d'aller à tf1 il était devenu un rival
non au contraire moi j'aurais aimé qu'il
reste avec nous on leur a fait on a fait
des belles propositions mais voilà
aujourd'hui il est très heureux à tf1 et
peut-être qu'un jour on le rejoindra
mais eux à des fins côté gauche combien
de députés à l'assemblée nationale comme
un des députés l'assemblée nationale
alors sans rigoler alors je vais vous
dire je pense qu'on a je m'approprie 400
mais je sais plus non c'est ça 1 577 170
ma mère n'est pas loin de pression en
vain qu est-ce qu on ne peut plus rien
dire sans être taxé de sexiste à c'est
devenu compliqué on fait très attention
ballack qu'on fait bien plus qu'avant je
fais une émission qui s'appelle la
grosse rigolade maintenant je sais qu'il
ya jean marie bigard encore la semaine
prochaine laurent baffie et toute la
bande
je me dis à chaque fois j'espère que les
gens vont comprendre que c'est des
blagues ray